Bonjour à tous !
Aujourd'hui, on va parler
de suprématie quantique.
Alors derrière ce terme
un peu grandiloquent
se cache une avancée
technologique importante
qui a été annoncée
en octobre 2019
par les laboratoires
de recherche de Google.
Pour la première fois, un ordinateur quantique
a été capable de faire mieux
que les meilleurs
super ordinateurs du monde
en résolvant un problème qu'aucun
d'entre eux n'aurait plus résoudre en pratique.
Cette étape importante marque
la fin d'une course de vitesse
entre Google,
IBM,
Intel,
Microsoft
et quelques autres,
pour savoir qui le premier arriverait
à faire cette démonstration de force.
Dans cette vidéo je vais donc vous expliquer
en quoi consiste cette réalisation,
ce qu'elle signifie
en pratique,
et ce que ça implique pour les développements futurs
de l'informatique quantique
mais expliquons tout d'abord
comment fonctionne un ordinateur quantique
et ce qui le différencie
d'un ordinateur normal, dit classique.
Un processeur d'ordinateur classique stocke et manipule les données sous forme de bits.
Un bit, c'est une unité
élémentaire d'information
qui peut valoir
soit 0, soit 1.
Et que le processeur peut lire
et écrire de façon électronique,
sous forme de courant
et de tension électrique.
Toute l'information manipulée par un ordinateur
l'est donc sous forme de série de 0 et de 1,
qui permettent
de représenter
des nombres, des caractères, mais aussi
des images, de la musique, des vidéos, etc.
Or en mécanique quantique, vous le savez
peut-être, les règles du jeu changent.
Il est possible de réaliser
des systèmes physiques
qui peuvent être
dans ce qu'on appelle un état superposé.
Vous connaissez sans doute
l'image du chat de Schrödinger,
qui est en quelque sorte
à la fois mort et vivant.
Eh bien on peut utiliser ce principe pour créer ce qu'on appelle des bits quantiques,
ou qubits,
qui peuvent stocker l'information
non pas sous forme
soit de 0,
soit de 1
mais comme une superposition
des deux
qui peut avoir
des proportions variables.
Alors ici j'utilise
ce symbole bizarre,
qui est la notation habituelle des physiciens
pour désigner les états quantiques.
Précision importante, un qubit n'est pas forcément
dans un état superposé
il peut très bien être
dans un état purement 0 ou purement 1.
On appelle cela
des états propres.
L'intérêt d'utiliser des qubits, c'est que ça permet
en quelque sorte de manipuler les 2 états à la fois
et donc
de gagner du temps
de faire d'une pierre, deux coups.
Or dit comme ça, on a envie de penser qu'un ordinateur quantique permet juste d'aller 2 fois plus vite,
mais regardez ce qui se passe
si on prend plusieurs qubits:
imaginons que dans un processeur
d'ordinateur normal,
on ait 3 bits pour stocker
de l'information,
au total le processeur à 8 états possibles
000,
001,
010,
011, etc.
Mais si dans un processeur quantique,
on a trois qubits
et qu'on arrive
à les manipuler ensemble ,
alors, un seul état
du processeur
peut représenter
une superposition quantique,
un mélange
des 8 états propres.
On fait donc
d'une pierre, 8 coups.
Et de façon plus générale,
si on a N qubits,
on peut s'en servir pour représenter
une superposition de 2 puissance N états.
Donc le gain augmente de façon exponentielle
avec le nombre de qubits.
Avec 10 qubits,
ça fait un facteur 1000
20 qubits,
plus d'un million, etc.
L'intérêt
d'un ordinateur quantique,
c'est donc la possibilité d'effectuer
des calculs beaucoup plus rapidement,
en bénéficiant
d'une forme de parallélisme.
Alors j'insiste sur le côté
"une forme de parallélisme",
parce que j'ai été obligé
de simplifier.
Un ordinateur quantique,
c'est pas juste un ordinateur qui va plus vite
et sur lequel on pourrait faire tourner
Windows ou alors son jeu vidéo préféré.
Et c'est même pas non plus comme
d'avoir plein d'ordinateurs en parallèle à sa disposition,
c'est plus compliqué
et plus restrictif que ça.
C'est plutôt
un type particulier d'ordinateur,
on devrait même plutôt parler
de processeurs quantiques,
qui ne fonctionne qu'avec des algorithmes spécifiques,
qui ne sont pas ceux
des processeurs classiques.
Et toutes les choses qu'on a l'habitude de faire avec un ordinateur classique ne sont pas susceptibles d'être accéléré avec un processeur quantique.
Parmi les algorithmes quantiques
très prometteur il y a celui de Glover.
Qui permettrait d'accélérer
la recherche dans des bases de données,
ce qui est quand même potentiellement
assez utile dans certaines applications.
Il y a aussi
le fameux algorithme de Shor,
du nom
du mathématicien Peter Shor,
qui permet de décomposer un nombre entier en facteur premier.
La décomposition d'un nombre en facteur premier c'est par exemple
calculer que 34081,
et bien c'est 197 x 173.
Et trouver ce genre de décomposition est un problème qui devient de plus en plus difficile avec un ordinateur classique
quand les nombres deviennent très grand.
Et d'ailleurs pas mal de protocoles de sécurité se basent sur le fait que si on choisit des nombres suffisamment grand
et bien c'est impossible, en pratique, de trouver cette décomposition.
Le souci qu'on pourrait avoir c'est qu'un ordinateur quantique utilisant l'algorithme de Shor,
pourrait faire ça beaucoup plus vite.
Et donc compromettre la sécurité de pas mal de communication et de transaction aujourd'hui.
Heureusement on va voir
qu'on en est encore très loin.
Alors qu'a donc réussi à faire Google exactement ?
La première chose qu'il faut dire c'est que des ordinateurs quantiques,
on sait en faire depuis déjà une vingtaine d'années c'est uniquement dans les labos de recherche.
Car la plupart ne peuvent résoudre que des problèmes complètement évident :
par exemple réussir une décomposition en facteur premier avec l'algorithme de Shor,
mais uniquement pour des nombres pas trop grand.
Le record actuel c'est :
4 088 459
Qui vaut 2017x2027
En 2012, le physicien John Preskill a introduit le terme de "suprématie quantique",
pour désigner le jour où un ordinateur quantique
arriverait pour la première fois, à résoudre un problème qu'un ordinateur classique ne pourrait pas résoudre.
Et c'est donc cette étape que Google vient visiblement de franchir.
Alors deux choses à propos de ce concept. Bon déjà le terme est pas génial
suprématie ça a pas des très bonnes connotations
John Preskill lui même
reconnaît volontiers a posteriori
que la dénomination est pas terrible
mais bon le terme est resté
l'autre point c'est que cette définition de la suprématie quantique
ça n'est pas
une définition absolue
en théorie un
ordinateur classique peut toujours simuler un ordinateur quantique et donc résoudre
exactement les mêmes problèmes que lui
mais en pratique si le temps de calcul sur l'ordinateur classique est monstrueux et bien c'est là qu'on parle de suprématie quantique
pour atteindre ce résultat Google a fabriqué un processeur quantique comportant 53 qubits. Ce processeur peut donc en principe
représenter une superposition de deux puissance 53 états c'est-à-dire environ dix mille milliards
pour démontrer la suprématie quantique il leur fallait donc résoudre un problème impossible à résoudre en pratique par le meilleur super-ordinateur actuel
alors intuitivement on pourrait penser que ce soit par exemple
décomposer en facteur premier un nombre immense
et bien non pour des raisons qu'on verra plus tard utilisez l'algorithme de Shor était totalement impossible avec leur système
et ils ont donc choisi un autre problème pour leur démonstration de force. C'est un problème qu'on appelle
l'échantillonnage d'un circuit quantique et il a comme particularité d'être assez artificiel et inutile car il n'y a pas d'application pratique
mais en tant qu'étape scientifique pour atteindre la suprématie quantique et bien il n'y a pas besoin que ça serve à quelque chose
alors qu'est ce que c'est un circuit quantique. Dans un processeur classique on stocke l'information sous forme de bit. Je l'ai dit
et pour les manipuler modifier leur valeur on utilise des opérations élémentaires qu'on appelle des portes logiques
vous en connaissez peut-être
quelques-unes, la porte NON,
qui inverse
la valeur d'un bit,
la porte ET,
la porte OU, etc.
ce sont des opérations logiques qui fixe
la valeur de certains bits en fonction d'autres
tous les calculs que fait
un processeur classique
peuvent se résumer à l'application
de portes logiques bien choisies
et bien pour un processeur quantique c'est presque pareil
il existe aussi des opérations qui peuvent transformer les états des qubits et qu'on appelle des portes logiques quantiques
il en existe tout un tas un beaucoup plus que des portes logiques classiques
si on prend un groupe de qubit d'une certaine taille qu'on lui applique une porte quantique on le transforme
et si on lui applique toute une série de portes quantiques, on forme ce qu'on appelle un circuit quantique
un circuit quantique c'est donc une série d'opérations qui va s'appliquer sur un ensemble de qubit pour le transformer et modifier son état
alors imaginons qu'on est trois qubit et un circuit quantique formé d'un certain nombre de portes successives
supposons également que l'état initial ça soit simplement l'état
000 un état propre
après l'application du circuit le qubit tu vas être dans un état différent a priori un état superposé
qui va être une superposition des huit états propres
et je voulais dit dans une superposition il y a des proportions et donc des coefficients on va les noter a, b, c, etc
L'application du circuit a transformé l'état 000 en un état superposé dont les coefficients vont dépendre du circuit qu'on a appliqué
si on applique un autre circuit constitué de différentes portes quantiques pas dans le même ordre on aura des coefficients différents
maintenant un point essentiel à comprendre c'est qu'à la fin de l'opération quand le processeur quantique est dans un certain état
la composition de cet état et bien on la connaît pas et s'affiche pas sur un écran
si on veut connaître l'état il faut le mesurer
et la mesure c'est une opération bien particulière qu'on doit faire sur le processeur
ce qu'on aimerait quand on fait cette mesure c'est qu'elle nous donne par exemple les valeurs des huit coefficients de façon à ce qu'on sache
dans quelle état exact est le processeur
malheureusement en mécanique quantique ça ne se passe pas comme ça
ce que la mesure va nous donner c'est un état propre pris au hasard parmi les huit états possibles
mais la probabilité d'avoir chacune des réponses va dépendre des coefficients
plus le coefficient est élevé plus la réponse associé sera probable
si on fait la mesure qu'une seule fois et bien on aura qu'une réponse par exemple 011 mais on a le droit de recommencer
sauf qu'en mécanique quantique une mesure détruit l'état superposés et donc il faut reprendre depuis le début en appliquant à nouveau le circuit quantique
mais si on répète cette procédure plein de fois et qu'on fait un histogramme pour représenter combien de fois on a obtenu chaque réponse
eh bien on aura certaines réponses
plus probables que d'autres
et ce d'autant plus que les coefficients sont grands dans l'état qu'on mesure
faire ce genre de manipulation c'est à dire appliquer un circuit faire la mesure et recommencer plein de fois c'est ce qu'on appelle faire un
échantillonnage du circuit quantique. Ce travail d'échantillonnage on peut aussi le simuler avec un ordinateur classique
Il existe des algorithmes qui si on leur donne la description du circuit quantique
peuvent calculer exactement ce qui va se passer dans le processeur quantique
c'est juste
potentiellement plus long
mais faire ce même calcul à la fois sur le processeur quantique et sur un ordinateur classique
ça permet de faire deux choses
d'une part comparer les temps de calculs pour voir de combien le processeur quantique est plus rapide et d'autre part
valider que le processeur quantique a donné une bonne réponse c'est à dire un échantillonnage du circuit qui est plausible
bien, alors venons dans le détail à ce qu'a réalisé l'équipe de Google
Pour vous expliquez le principe
de l'échantillonnage de circuit quantique
j'ai pris le cas simplifié
d'un processeur quantique à 3 qubits
le processeur conçu par Google qu'ils ont appelé Sycamore, possède 53 qubits
Vous voyez ici une image au microscope qu'il représente hein, il fait environ deux centimètres
Ce qui est essentiel, c'est que les 53 qubits qu'il contient, fonctionnent ensemble comme un seul objet quantique. On dit qu'ils sont intriqués
et c'est ça qui est difficile à faire hein c'est pas juste des qubits les uns à côté des autres
alors petite anecdote pourquoi à 53 qubits et bien parce que dans le processeur il y en a en fait
54 mais il se trouve qu'un des qubits était dysfonctionnel et donc ils n'ont pas pu l'utiliser
ça montre un truc intéressant c'est que ce processeur ils en ont pas 150 exemplaires
c'est une pièce unique qui a dû être
affreusement compliquée à fabriquer
et donc si un qubit ne marche pas et ben,
on va faire sans.
D'un point de vue technologique les qubits sont réalisées avec ce qu'on appelle des jonctions supraconductrices
imaginer des minuscules bobines de fil supraconducteurs le tout étant refroidis dans une grosse enceinte a seulement 20 millikelvin donc
0,02 degré au dessus du zéro absolu cette température glaciale c'est à la fois pour avoir l'effet supraconducteur mais aussi surtout parce que la température
détruit la superposition dans les culs bits donc il faut garder tout ça bien au froid pour minimiser les erreurs de calcul
à l'extérieur ce processeur quantique est relié à toute une électronique plus classique qui permet de le piloter et de faire entre autres deux choses
premièrement appliquer les portes quantiques qu'on souhaite et c'est ça qui en fait vraiment un processeur
programmable de l'extérieur. Si vous imaginez un circuit quantique de votre choix eh bien on peut décider de l'appliquer au processeur
et deuxièmement effectuer la mesure de l'état quand on a fini d'appliquer le circuit
pour obtenir une réponse
et la stocker dans un système externe
Tout à l'heure dans mon exemple à 3 qubits lors d'une mesure la réponse était un truc du genre
et y en avait huit possibles
dans le cas de Sycamore, la réponse
sera une chaîne de 53 caractère du genre
0 1 1 1 0 1 0 0 etc.
et il n'y a pas loin de dix mille milliards de chaînes différentes possibles
Pour tester leurs processeurs les chercheurs de Google ont imaginé des circuits plus ou moins complexes consistant en l'application
successive d'un bloc de portes quantiques
que l'on répète un certain nombre de fois
on appelle ça les cycles et donc plus le nombre de cycles est élevé plus le circuit sera grand et plus le calcul sera à
priori
difficile dans le cas le plus extrême testé par Google avec 20 cycles pour le circuit
il a fallu à Sycamore 200 secondes pour répéter l'opération un million de fois et donc avoir un échantillonnage avec un million de mesures
et les chercheurs de Google ont calculé que pour faire la même chose sur un superordinateur
possédant
un million de cœurs
il aurait fallu
10000 ans
Alors ça paraît très impressionnant
mais ça pose une question
s'ils ne peuvent justement pas faire
le calcul avec un ordinateur classique
comment ils savent le temps que ça prendrait et surtout comment ils s'assurent que le processeur quantique a donné une bonne réponse
et bien avant de faire le cas super complexe dont on vient de parler ils ont d'abord traiter des cas plus simples
pour lesquels on pouvait faire la comparaison
il y a trois types de simplification possible
utiliser moins de qubits
utiliser des circuits
avec moins de cycles
et enfin utiliser certains types particuliers
de circuits qui sont simplifiables
et qui se prête mieux aux calculs sur un ordinateur classique
ils ont ainsi comparé des cas avec seulement 14 cycles et un nombre de qubits allant de 12 à 53
et également des cas à
53 qubits avec un nombre variable de cycles
mais uniquement
pour des circuits simplifiables
et à chaque fois le processeur quantique fonctionnait comme prévu
et donc pour le cas le plus complexe 53 qubits, 20 cycles et un circuit quantique non simplifiable
on peut donc légitimement penser que Sycamore a correctement fonctionné également. Pour faire les calculs classiques
correspondants et vérifier les résultats dans les cas où c'était possible, les chercheurs de Google ont quand même dû sortir l'artillerie lourde
en utilisant notamment le super-ordinateur le plus puissant du monde appelé Summit ainsi que pas mal de puissance des serveurs cloud de Google
cela a notamment permis de faire des extrapolations sur les temps de calcul et d'estimer que dans le cas le plus complexe
une tâche équivalente aurait pris environ dix mille ans sur un ordinateur comme Summit
Alors petite précision mais importante quand on parle de science, ce travail a été publié dans une revue scientifique la revue nature
et donc il a été soumis à un travail d'évaluation par des chercheurs extérieurs
ce n'est pas la garantie absolue que tout soit correct mais c'est pour souligner que cette annonce c'est pas juste non plus un
communiqué de presse de Google où ils auraient raconté ce qu'ils voulaient
Alors au total que nous apprend ce travail. Et bien déjà il montre que le calcul quantique est
possible il y a encore des chercheurs qui n'étaient pas convaincus que des processeurs quantiques puissent vraiment en pratique à mener à une accélération
est là bien c'est le cas
d'autre part cela montre que Google aurait atteint la fameuse suprématie quantique c'est à dire que pour la première fois de l'histoire
un processeur quantique a fait un calcul qu'un ordinateur classique n'aurait pas pu faire
en un temps raisonnable
maintenant un point qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que cette notion de suprématie quantique
qui met en compétition les processeurs quantiques et les ordinateurs classiques
elle est susceptible de changer au cours du temps au fur et à mesure de l'évolution des technologies et des algorithmes
c'est par exemple ce qu'a essayé de montrer IBM au moment de l'annonce de Google
alors forcément ils sont en compétition donc IBM a tout intérêt à essayer de minimiser l'exploit de Google
et pour faire ça ils ont écrit un article argumentant que le calcul qui soi-disant prendrait 10 mille ans d'après Google
En fait il serait possible de le faire en seulement trois jours si on utilise un autre algorithme.
Alors c'est intéressant de regarder de plus près et de comprendre comment
pour simuler le calcul quantique sur un ordinateur classique donc pour faire cette comparaison
on utilise normalement des algorithmes qui sont assez sophistiqués et qui comme toujours en algorithmique sont le résultat d'un compromis entre
l'utilisation de la mémoire la RAM est celle du processeur
et IBM a proposé un truc radical c'est d'utiliser un max de RAM pour gagner du temps de processeurs. Le super-ordinateur
Summit dont j'ai parlé et que google a utilisé c'est justement IBM qui l'a fabriqué
même s'il appartient
à un labo national américain
et sa mémoire RAM c'est
250 millions de gigas
or il se trouve que 250 millions de giga c'est à peu près la RAM qu'il faut pour stocker entièrement
l'état complet
d'un processeur quantique à 53 qubits
et je voudrais déjà
que vous réalisiez l'ampleur
de ce truc de dingue
le processeur Sycamore quand il est dans un certain état quantique
cet état est une superposition
des deux puissance 50 états propres possibles
et donc il faut autant de coefficients pour le décrire complètement
comme 2 puissance 53 c'est à peu près 10 millions de milliards
pour juste stocker l'état quantique de Sycamore
il faut toute la RAM
du super-ordinateur Summit
Et en fait si on fait ce choix radical
de prendre autant de RAM
Ibm a expliqué qu'on pouvait utiliser un algorithme, un peu moins subtile moins gourmand en temps de calcul
et donc faire l'ensemble de l'opération en seulement trois jours au lieu de dix mille ans. Alors pourquoi pas mais plusieurs commentaires là dessus
premièrement ils ont dit que c'était possible ils l'ont pas encore fait
le super-ordinateur le plus puissant du monde il n'est pas non plus en self service à la demande
ensuite même si c'était vrai le processeur Sycamore serait quand même toujours mille fois plus rapide et aussi 10 millions de fois moins gourmand
en énergie accessoirement. Mais surtout le jour où Google gagne ne serait ce que quelques qubits, disons 60 au lieu de 53
pour que la façon de faire d'Ibm marche il faudrait cent fois plus de ram dans le super-ordinateur
donc même si l'objection est intéressante elle n'est forcément que très temporaire
malgré tout il faut le rappeler le problème qui a résolu le processeur quantique Sycamore n'est à ce stade qu'un problème relativement inutile
hein, sans répercussion directe à part peut-être la génération de nombres aléatoires ce qui peut avoir des applications concrètes
et surtout retenez bien qu'on est encore très loin de pouvoir utiliser un tel processeur quantique
pour résoudre des problèmes comme la décomposition au facteur premier. la raison c'est que Sycamore fait pleins pleins d'erreurs
en effet un qubit, c'est assez instable et sensible à tout un tas de défauts de fabrication et de perturbations extérieures
c'est pour ça qu'on les refroidit
à 20 millikelvins d'ailleurs
et quand un qubit est perturbé, ça créé une erreur de calcul
les chercheurs de Google ont mesuré le taux d'erreur de leur processeur c'est environ
0,2 pour cent quand on applique une porte quantique et 3% quand on effectue une mesure
alors c'est peu mais sur un circuit composé de nombreuses portes et bien ça s'accumule très vite. Dans un problème comme
l'échantillonnage de circuits quantique c'est pas dramatique
on prend plein d'échantillons et si certains sont faux ça ressort comme du bruit mais on arrive quand même à conclure certaines choses
et c'est d'ailleurs en quelque sorte l'évolution de ce rapport signal sur bruit avec la complexité des circuits
qui a servi à Google à faire la démonstration du fonctionnement de Sycamore
mais pour un algorithme comme l'algorithme de Shor celui qui permet de factoriser des nombres, la moindre erreur et le calcul est ruiné
Sycamore fait donc beaucoup trop d'erreurs pour espérer pouvoir faire ça
pour progresser dans ce domaine on peut faire deux choses
la première c'est
améliorer le processeur pour qu'il soit plus fiable plus robuste qu'il fasse moins d'erreurs et là il y a un petit peu de marge
la deuxième c'est d'utiliser ce qu'on appelle des codes correcteurs d'erreurs
il s'agit de procédures de contrôle qui permettent de repérer quand des erreurs se produisent et de les corriger
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait déjà depuis longtemps avec les processeurs classiques et qu'on peut faire aussi avec les processeurs quantiques
même s'il a fallu imaginer des codes correcteurs
spécifiques quantiques, le plus connu étant dû au mathématicien Peter Shor toujours lui qui décidément a beaucoup oeuvré pour
l'informatique quantique. Mais le problème de ces codes correcteurs quantiques c'est qu'ils obligent à multiplier le nombre de qubits et qu'ils sont
incroyablement gourmands. Pour vous donner une idée on peut estimer que pour atteindre la suprématie quantique en réussissant la factorisation d'un très grand nombre
il faudrait un ordinateur quantique à environ 2000 qubits à condition que ceux ci fonctionnent de façon parfaite hein, sans jamais d'erreurs
mais comme les qubits ne sont pas parfaits on a besoin de codes correcteurs quantiques et on estime que pour pouvoir les implémenter
il faudrait plutôt environ un milliard de qubits, au lieu de juste 2000.
1 milliard de qubits et on en est à 53
donc même en supposant que le nombre de qubits
double tous les deux ans un peu à la façon de la loi de moore pour l'informatique classique
et bien vous voyez qu'on a encore un peu le temps de voir venir
voilà merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo je rappelle que j'en ai fait une autre qui présente de façon un peu plus détaillé les principes de
l'ordinateur quantique et que comme toujours vous pouvez trouver des compléments et des références dans le billet de blog qui accompagne la vidéo
comme toujours abonné vous mettez la cloche tout ça les actualités de la chaîne c'est sur facebook et twitter
et je vous dis à bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo